خمسه اسابيع على الحرب البريه لم تظهر حتى
الان كتائب القسام عجزا في
القتال تشير تقديرات اسرائيليه الى ان
الالويه التي تقاتل شمالا لن تطلب دعما من
الويه مناطق القطاع الاخرى تقرر اسرائيل
توسيع العمليه اوكلت مهمه العمليات في
الجنوب للفرقه الثامنه
في الجيش الاسرائيلي وتتشكل من اللواء
المظلي
ال واللواء المظلي
الخم اضافه الى لواء عوز ويتشكل من وحده
دوف دوفان ووحده ماجلان ووحده
ايجوس دفعت اسرائيل ايضا باللواء المدرع
السابع ولواء جفعاتي ولواء كفير ولواء
كرياتي واللواء الخامس والكتيبه
12 في المقابل سيقاتل في خان يونس احد
ابرز الويه النخبه في القسام وهو من
الاعلى تدريبا
وتجهيزا لواء خان يونس لكن لا تتوفر
معلومات دقيقه حول هياكل القياده وهرمي
اتخاذ القرارات ما دون
استراتيجيه تعد العمليه العسكريه في
المحاف ظه واحده من الاكثر تعقيدا في مسار
الحرب تتوفر فيها جميع العناصر التي
تخشاها الجيوش التقليديه في حروب المدن
تصعب البيئه الحضاريه من مهمه الجيوش في
بقعه جغرافيه صغيره ذات كثافه سكانيه
عاليه والاستعداد للقتال في مثل هذه
التضاريس الجغرافيه
والديمغرافيا دونه صعوبات هائله تعتمد
اسرائيل على كلاسيكيات الجيوش النظاميه
حمله جويه باستخدام ذخائر خارقه للتحصينات
لاستهداف عقد القياده
والتحكم قبل المناورات البريه اصدرت كليه
الاركان في الجيش الامريكي وست بوينت
تقريرا تحذر فيه من مخاطر التوغل
البري يقول التقرير ان استخلاص عبري يؤكد
ان القوه الجويه لم تحقق النتائج المرجوه
في عمليات سابقه
مماثله الله
اكبر اما القسام فتعتمد في القتال على ما
يسمى اصطلاحا التشكيل الهجيم اي وجود قوه
مقاتله
من النخبه التي تقتبس من الجيوش النظاميه
ارتفاع مستوى الاداء
والانضباط وبعض التقاليد
العسكريه بان الجندي ينفذ اوامر القياده
كان يكمن في موقع واحد لاسابيع وان لا
يشتبك مع العدو تحت اي ظرف وان يتفادى
انكشاف موقعه مثل ما شهدنا في كمين
المغازي
ضرب
اضرب وهناك الوحدات الميدانيه التي تختص
بالاشتباك المباشر والقدره على المناوره
وسرعه التنفيذ والانسحاب وتتكون من
مجموعات صغيره العدد من فرد واحد او
اكثر طورت القسام من تكتيكاتها وباتت
قادره على الاشتباك فوق الارض وتحت الارض
دربت مقاتليها على التكيف مع نقص الاكسجين
وغياب مصادر الضوء الطبيعي وارتفاع مخاطر
مواجهه هجمات غير تقليديه كالغاز السام
الذي استخدمته اسرائيل في بعض الانفاق
دفعت اسرائيل بوحدتها من محورين رئيسيين
توغلت القوات من كيسوفيم بمستوى القراره
لتعزل خانيونس كليا عن المحافظه الوسطى
قطعت شارع صلاح الدين واستكملت سيرها عبر
اراضي زراعيه حتى الخط الساحلي غربا عند
شارع
الرشيد بالتوازي هاجمت من محور جنوبي شرقي
من الفخار
والهدف استخدام شارع صلاح الدين كخط فاصل
جغرافيا بين شرق المحافظه وغربها وبالتالي
محاوله تشتيت جهد لواء خان يونس عند هذه
المرحله ومع انتهاء الاسبوع الاول للهجوم
بدات متاعب اسرائيل
الفعليه تحولت المدينه نفسها من مسرح
للقتال الى وسيله
للحرب العقبه الثانيه تمثلت بتحديات الكشف
عن الانفاق
وتدميرها يعد تنظيف الانفاق بمثابه كابوس
للجنود فهي عمليه بطيئه وقاتله وتعطل
امكانيه استخدام التقنيات الحديثه على
نطاق واسع والتي يعتمد عليها الجيش
الاسرائيلي وفق عقيده معالوت اي
التفوق اساءت اسرائيل تقدير قوه خصمها
ورمت بثقلها على التكنولوجيا وهذان خطان
قاتلان في حروب المدن فهمه فرق المشاه
بحسب الامريكيين تكمن في تحديد مواقع
العدو
وتدميرها وان تمكن العدو من تحييد هذه
المعادله فسيكون الاجهاز عليه امرا
[موسيقى]
مستحيلا